[Music]
welcome back to the career boys well
we're gonna do an exciting episode of
hot seat with a boy jr over here
hot seat just if you've never played
before you know it's where we like to
get real intimate real close with our
fellow guests over here now you're
talking about not jerking off so i'm
ready for this oh yeah yeah but we are
so talking about joking that's what
makes it hot yeah it starts cold and
then it gets hot starts real cold
set it off with a sterile question
that's very boring yeah yeah
give us a sterile question
are you more of a pomade guy gel or
moose that's actually a pretty good
question i like that one that's a lot
made it just like it holds the asian
hair dude you got palm mate on i got
palmetto right now i think what about
hair wax do i care about i don't you
know honestly i don't know the
difference okay me neither i wanted you
to answer that [ __ ]
now dude but gel makes it to like i
think i wore gel when i was like in
eighth grade yeah that was like la looks
part ellie look look it's all spiky
because then like white kids put it on
their hair like it would do something
different whenever mine it was always
straight anime like right away right up
right yeah stiff and you can see your
scalp whenever i gel my hair you can see
my scalp for some reason i never met you
before
who are you friends with here uh i know
gil oh here in this room
i know nick we met each other
actually
2019 right yeah we all trained together
and through gilbert that's how we met
each other oh so you
know next group through gilbert i didn't
know they knew each other i met him on
the explore page of instagram wow you
[ __ ] slid into his dms yeah damn what
would you look at what was that asian i
don't know i saw you performing and i
was like oh this dude's funny yeah he's
there and then that's how i hit you up
and i was like hey would you ever want
to come down on jk news yeah that's
right and then i think so he didn't know
that he knew nick and all that no for
context performing means stand-up comedy
but he was doing like music and comedy
it was tight which is hard to do very
hard to do so you go on an acoustic
guitar [ __ ] make jokes yeah yeah
happy hanukkah happy honey come on yo
face yeah
nuts on a jewish girl yes i mean
i have that's nice
i don't care what you believe you know
although man okay
since you're talking about that already
which ethnicity screams the loudest
screams
in general not not with sex or anything
it's a jewish girl
in what situation
i don't know why it feels like my heart
says like anything like south america
and hispanic i don't know why they're
more expressive i'm saying this like
from experience
[Applause]
it feels like a celebration or like a
pinata just like like like a pinata just
opens that's so poetic it's beautiful
right you're just wanting all the candy
here let me just open your pinata
do you consider yourself a latino
because you have latin mixtures oh does
it feel like any latin lover features
colonization uh why am i legitimate from
colonization
no i don't know
it's weird i've never heard that one
because it's always like pacific
islander or asian but never got one
latino i did audition for latino role
did you get it no
it was it was in the time where everyone
was like no man only go for rolls under
like your ethnicity like
i i still went out for it hell yeah let
me go see if i can get this latino role
i swear i've seen a mexican guy that
looks like you before what's up what's
the ethnicity
which which ethnicity do you have sex
with that you're like oh be quiet and
then shut them and shut their mouth yeah
i don't know i want them to be free dude
freedom of speech in there oh that's the
time man hey that's cool you're pretty
cool dude you're pretty cool
this guy tried to trip you up
look you know some ethnicities you're
like you're ruining the time especially
the japanese porn
i never had sex with
me thank god japanese-american girls
don't [ __ ] moan like that it's not
like a squeaky chair
because i'm sitting
collateral damage dude
let me show you what you're thinking jr
why why did you get into stand-up comedy
or how did you like what made you go
like i'mma [ __ ] make people laugh
today uh dude i took a class in college
i took there was a stand-up comedy class
and i went to where where'd you go
college you uc davis wow damn they got
those kind of classes in colleges there
was a guy who was who
was doing it as like an elective course
you could take for theater so i took
that oh ty who's your teacher his name
is brett duggan he lives here now and
then you were like i love this [ __ ] bro
i got hooked man it's like a drug dude
for the first one when did you start
incorporating like the guitar in your
act it was like a year in oh so i
started with that class and then another
comedy class uh part of the assignment
was to write a comedy song
and i wrote one called no homo that's
time what was your favorite line in that
song
uh did i remember i did something i
didn't tell it about prison sex in it or
something nice yeah that's that's a good
kind yeah you got to say it right after
comedy for a nice guy oh yeah yeah dude
i don't know man i think on stage i just
like like to talk about that stuff yeah
i wouldn't take you for like a no-homo
prison gangster sex
yeah it's like not jacking off for a
year but then on stage i just talked
about jacking off
that's true comic right there no i don't
know man i don't know i don't know where
it comes from how long have you been
doing it uh 10 years
10 years yeah wow what's your favorite
city to perform in oh man i love
sacramento and san diego weather right
the weather san diego diego's where i
recorded my album just because it's like
my favorite city you got an album yeah
is it like comedy album or like you also
just sing outside of comedy comedy
comedy oh [ __ ] it's on spotify mm-hmm
but then spotify i think just removed
all comedy or something really yeah do
you hear about that because they didn't
have the licensing for it
and they just got found out for that or
something so there's how do you get
licensing for it yeah they didn't have
like the proper stuff to like actually
pay out so somebody was like um excuse
me you can't say hana come like we don't
have licensing for hanukkah yeah that
sounds like a blurry line like so it
just can't be funny yeah who's the
comedian referee that's like yup you
could do it
and like you can't do it who's that guy
what's that dmx song where it's singing
christmas songs rudolph the red red
that's so weird i think it was like a
legal issue that they're figuring out
right now how to like have comedy on
there and pay the comics because i think
before they weren't they weren't paying
them properly but what's the difference
between that versus a musician that's
doing comedy or maybe those maybe those
royalties are worked out already oh got
it got it yeah because this is like
spoken word yeah so they weren't sure
how to pay what's the what's the word uh
describe the time that you bond the
worst through the philippines man really
i was in my home country they're like
yeah so i went up what happened
this is not funny this is so stupid
because how come i saw joe coy go to
philippines and he killed it he crashed
i wish he was my son bart is a very
asian dad though that's something very
ancient that entered the question is so
funny is uh joe koi is better than you
i went up this guy did uh stand up in
tagalog and then he crushed it like 30
minutes straight and then i went up and
did it in english and they were just
like no i want that tagalog it was
better
and then and then so like bombed like 30
minutes straight is it because they
didn't understand the ref no they they
understand even with the guitar they
didn't like it no i did and then they
they brought the guy back on oh that bad
yeah double disc damn he's like no bring
the other guy this guy's so bad yeah
they're like that made me sad
[Laughter]
i want to laugh i don't like that one i
didn't like him that one not so much how
did you feel after it was weird because
my friends were there and [ __ ] like my
friends were like visiting the
philippines so i you know that thing i
had to explain to them afterwards like
you know sometimes that happens
yeah they were like nah did you say that
they never saw you again was it your
good material it's just the crowd i did
all my best [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] are you
gonna go back to the philippines anytime
soon i probably i want to yeah was it
your only philippine show you see what
joe feels like when he does that
have you done other shows in the
philippines i have yeah so they were
okay or like yes i had good sets because
i was like if that's your only show i'm
like maybe you need a new set for the
philippines specifically philippine set
i know man damn where'd you smash it the
most like the hardest like you're like i
[ __ ] roasted this right you know
there's a show in in vegas
called the dirty at 12 30. yeah so fun i
have a song called amputee girlfriend
that's good other rooms i can't really
do it but over there dude it's like
30 at 12 30 is it like midnight that's
when it's at 12 30.
yeah so the show finishes like at two in
the morning everybody in there is
amputee it's crazy they love it dude the
vegas is crazy how do they clap
there's two plastic arms
just
what's the uh
weirdest porno you ever jacked off to
damn no dude i know specifically because
i know it's because i remember
afterwards thinking like you know after
you come you felt ashamed i knew i
probably should have jerked off to that
i know that feeling was that one what
was it
it was like halloween and so i think
this girl was like dressed up as like a
demon so you're like feeling like that
that's there it's not that bad no and
then what happened
what happened what's the part that's
[ __ ] up uh well just because it was so
realistic it wasn't like you know i'm
wearing like a like i got this at party
city demon outfit she had like the
contacts like her eyes were all blacked
out oh like horror film yeah costume
horror i felt like i was jerking off to
a horror film but you liked it a little
bit
it was a part of me that i didn't know
was in there that i got to know that i
got to go
you were just in the mode of the the
season like if you did that during
[ __ ] thanksgiving i've been like bro
what's wrong with you
halloween was over yeah or like easter
easter oh even worse
because during that time you got to do
easter bunny porn you know
during christmas you got to do the whole
santa orgy [ __ ] you know it only makes
sense today's video is brought to you by
amazon music since you're listening to
the show i think it's safe to say that
you love podcasts and comedy talk shows
oh i do and you'll find a ton of
binge-worthy podcasts just like ours on
amazon music amazon music has more than
10 million free podcast episodes to
listen to like hilarious podcast
smartlist one week before everyone else
ad free right on amazon music but amazon
music isn't just for listening to
podcasts they have thousands of music
stations and top playlists to listen to
for free and no matter what you're
listening to you can go hands-free with
alexa if you're like me and you want
your music on demand and ad-free you
have to try amazon music unlimited that
gives you unlimited access to over
75
million songs as well as podcasts music
videos and much much more with amazon
music unlimited you can listen to any
song anywhere even offline with
unlimited skips you know sometimes i'm
listening to my amazon music
and i'm working out and there'll be a
sick playlist but some of the songs you
don't like so i can able to skip it
every single time
and if i'm in a place like i'm in a
hotel room and i can't connect to the
wi-fi what i like about i could pre
download that playlist so if i'm working
out in a hotel room i can still listen
to my favorite workout playlists so if
you've never tried amazon music
unlimited now is the time to try because
you can have three months of unlimited
access for free all you have to do is go
to amazonmusic.com
otr pod to get three months of unlimited
access for free go check it out see if
you like all of the shows on there and
if it's good for you there's no credit
card required so there's no reason not
to try it go to amazonmusic.com
otr pod yeah so this is the point of the
uh episode at 11 minutes and 29 seconds
well we like to take a little bit warmer
a little bit deeper okay so okay uh
regardless of jackknife when was the
last time you cried
dude oh [ __ ]
dude uh
[ __ ] like real real real quick
one of these like
yeah
yeah what are those looks like
right after i was jacking off
that demon
[ __ ]
i think it was wednesday what day is
today friday today's friday on wednesday
yeah what why oh dude i was that i was
at church and you know how they can like
pray for you and stuff yeah so i went up
i was like feeling good i was like i'd
probably just do like a a weak ass
prayer right now then i went up and like
she asked me some like real [ __ ] and i
started talking about
some like family stuff or something and
then she asked you she asked me i think
it was because like i didn't do
thanksgiving with my family this year i
did like i did it separate and so i was
just like
talking about how i haven't like talked
to a family member for like two years
and the second i like just started it i
was like you know in a good thing and
that she [ __ ] up your day dude
yeah the [ __ ] is wrong with you started
crying you have a bad relationship with
their parents no my parents was good
then what do you mean you have a senior
family have like a not a great
relationship with my brother
that's deep dude that is dude
what happened with you and your brother
oh he's one more okay yeah i don't know
you don't want to go yeah he wants to
pull 52 now he's 1252. yeah it goes up
we turned it up a little bit 1252. you
know it was kind of like what he was
talking about before too we had like a
yeah sociopathic brother too i had like
a strained relationship with him yeah
now [ __ ] his ass up for you dude yeah we
will we will now see danger boys yeah
even like saying this stuff on like you
know here i feel like i'm i don't i
don't know how if he saw it how you'd
respond to it so we haven't talked like
two years
and do you want to talk to him though
you want to like rekindle that uh
if it feels like good i think i would
but i think i'm like taking my time so
what about your upbringing that's cool
in the beginning
and it went weird we've like done we've
had some good times he's like a funny
guy you know yeah yeah older younger
older
how many years uh like a year and a half
oh okay so pretty that's different dude
one year that's like close that's pretty
close yeah i haven't talked to my
brother in like a decade so like i got
you beat homie oh yeah
try again man
[Laughter]
that's crazy
so who's the comedian you like you know
you don't really like to watch or do you
think is over hyped
somebody you don't really [ __ ] man
over hyped oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy man
we're like you deserve to be on the
stage like everyone's laughing and
you're just like what the [ __ ] is so
funny
i don't know i don't know if i can think
of a comic like that because every time
i see a comic even if everyone's
laughing i know like that
they've had to go through so much [ __ ]
to just like to get it there yeah to
even get it to that point unless they're
like stealing jokes and like it's really
really hacky or something who's the
number what kind of like style of comedy
you think is oh that's me that's not a
good question who do you think is really
hacky
you really want me to sit on something
yeah that's the point of the show we
need to turn it up a little bit yeah
submissions you don't have to you don't
have to answer that we just want to tag
them that's it
non-comedian it doesn't have to be in
the comedy scene so you don't like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up the situation you're in
your own ecosystem but if you could just
sock anybody in the face first and last
name who would it be person last name
how about
you don't have to do it but you asked me
to do it yeah who is it yeah yeah i have
a better question who would you want
which comedian would you want your
brother to fight to fight yeah they're
gonna fight each other and [ __ ] each
other up he had to fight him yeah oh god
man that's such a hard this is a hot
seat we gave him like 20 different
questions you gave him so many elements
to work with
we're just going to say this one's too
hard let's make it harder
i got it i got another one
i one even harder
who's your number one enemy in the cod
of cop in a comedy space who you got a
rival i don't think this guy has rivals
in the companies i don't know man i've
had like i've had [ __ ] where like i've
had a
thing where i've had to like talk to
other comics about what should i do in
this situation like i want to [ __ ] you
up but i don't know what to do but i
think i just had to just you gotta like
i don't know i gotta like let it go kind
of kind of thing or what's your how
about this what's your comedy pet peeve
like if you're performing with somebody
somebody like nice piece pump shoes or
something like that like what is
something that i really like is like man
i can't believe this guy did that or
that's kind of not that cool okay
something this isn't this isn't like a
big huge deal thing but when someone's
talking [ __ ] about somebody
and they were before them
oh and it's like well that guy can't
like say anything back or something they
just keep roasting the dude or something
to me it's like better if you can roast
and like
go back and forth yeah yeah yeah it's
almost like a low blow it's almost like
punching someone and running really fast
yeah yeah yeah you run away yeah wait
come back yeah yeah it feels like that
you can't even fight does someone ever
do that to you after like in a set uh
i've had a few times because i play
music so people will like talk [ __ ]
about like the music and stuff but
they'll try to punching bag you a little
bit they do have those stupid-ass hosts
sometimes that they don't have much
material so they'll purposely pronounce
mispronounce people's names because they
think it's funny i had a guy who was
like hey this is my good friend this is
my best friend and comedy dude i love
this guy give it up for aj gomez i was
like
and you're like
how is it even funny to someone in the
first time hearing your name
they'll just think you're aj goldberg
yes that's like what's that just funny
between you and him
do you have a really good heckler story
i did have a show in um
like washington but it was already like
a bad show it was like a bowling alley
slash casino slash like salsa night whoa
damn what the hell
somebody i think there was only like two
people in the audience but
for this kind of casino thing they they
have to have entertainment anyway so
they're like just keep going
and uh somebody was in the crowd like
they just started throwing like ice at
me oh my god and i was the opener i
wasn't even closing it out so i can't
like kick them out for the headliner and
like i asked like the security like
hey like can you guys get this guy out
like
they didn't do [ __ ] yeah he was just
drunk chucking ice at you yeah so i just
didn't get your guitar [ __ ] smash him
over the [ __ ] head with it i think i
was like two years in so i don't know
how to like handle a heckler or anything
people that make it deserve it man yeah
so much [ __ ] company's so hard yeah
dude did you ever have someone tell you
like that you're not going to make it in
comedy does that
that person never comes to mind [ __ ]
make it just set up a [ __ ] i think of
like joe coy right yeah joe messaged me
yeah that's a wreck i could only be one
filipino i don't know i saw your set in
the philippines
i killed it out there i don't know
[Laughter]
what's your greatest fear
in the world yes comedy or fear
commodities of the world world how about
both dude world war three bro
during the pandemic do you think it's
gonna happen i don't know i mean it it
feels like it every there's a sequel it
feels like there's gonna be if you if
you need a place to stay you could come
hang out with us
we got guns
that's what i think about like what
would i be in world war iii you'll be
the guy that drives the van you have a
lot of experience you did van life we
were talking about the gang bang bus
thing right the yellow the yellow bus
the yellow bus
bus
secret that's true
no i got covered during the pandemic and
then i watched like during the in the
van by yourself no no
[Laughter]
patient zero
this one was spreading it like bull rap
it's full
yeah i'm the one that brought it here
this guy was bad life being in 2019
and [ __ ] by himself oh [ __ ] after that i
just for some reason i just watched like
world war ii documentaries because i
think i really thought like world war
iii was gonna happen i think a lot of
people yeah once all the toilet paper
left the shelves man people were like
[ __ ]
i was stocking up in like beans and
[ __ ] rice like telling these guys
amen we gotta have a [ __ ] escape plan
yeah we're ready to go did you ever make
escape
never needed to what's the what piece of
laundry do you regret the most coming on
oh dude anything that's like a family
members really yeah like when you've
grown up as a kid you know busted nuts
on your like brother's sock or something
yeah like like a family sock on his
shirt that he was wearing because then i
when i see them where are you guys
shared clothes we just like counted
downs hand me down
gum
so do you see it like you see your mom
wearing the sock you're like oh why are
you wearing that one oh man like she's
walking out i think like you know you
know as a kid like when you just like oh
what's in this room like i need
something to come into or is that just
me i don't know i'm just saying it like
it's a very general you know when yeah
and uh prepare to just horny just do it
and then later you bust something when
you're young right that's right well we
also had like a shared computer it was
like i was at the age where we only had
one computer in the house yeah so we had
to do like a sneak mission into the
computer room yeah and stop in the
laundry room like grab something in
there to come into so
calm about it so proud of this show for
being able to like go from like your
greatest spirit to back to like
ejaculation like immediately you know
these are like my conversations with my
best friend is like either like coming
and crying like it's like when are you
thanks for calling us your best friends
man that's sick dude dude you guys are
very welcoming man thank you for sharing
this is a safe place bro it's a great
hot season it's a very safe place yeah
joe makes us feel safe he's going to
kill everybody for us if you want him to
yeah i like that you need somebody just
off that's your guy i won't do it
anymore because i'm i i pledge my
allegiance for abstinence and
non-violence abstinence and killing or
whatever never mind okay i got friends
and killing it
we need to rescind that offer i got
friends careful boys
[Music]
you